[Music]
uh
all right let's see what this i haven't
seen this one but it just i had to click
it because i saw the thumbnail crazy cat
lady explains meow meanings all right
let's see maybe i could learn from this
teaching you guys some ways that my
friends and i meow to one another to
communicate when words just seem a
little too difficult so hey merch is
that you
stop
that's not me
oh here we go i'm not a trans woman
yet first off we have the normal meow
that we just used mostly to get each
other's attention
meow
okay then we have the dis merch i have
i've been apologized to you right now
this is how i'm gonna start
communicating with you and there's
nothing i could do there's nothing to do
about it unfortunately
meow meow meow this just reminds me that
[ __ ] i was on night wave the other
night i was watching a picture of blay
only use me blade and i mean he was
[ __ ]
all borderline comatose drunk which is
normal for him but he was just hammered
like drinking egg or wobbling and i
guess they have a cat on the rv now so
there was just a mew in the background
he goes meow
satisfied now
i had that that's what my mustang
sounded like when it wouldn't start
it would be specifically okay then we
have the dissatisfied meow
i flooded it
you gotta hit the clutch
god damn it i'm gonna be here for a bit
[ __ ] you should probably cut the uh cut
the radio off you gotta be kicking me
you gotta be kidding me
i quit
bro remember wait i know i can't be a
part of this oh come on virgie that joke
was perfect
all right you've won me back thank you
hey
[Laughter]
this is so [ __ ] stupid can we get
back to this mental catastrophe
i hate you
you know this [ __ ] remember when like
uh when these broken [ __ ] used to
just want to like do a little bit of
molly and maybe suck your dick yeah and
now it's like now they want it now they
want to groom you with their tongue
apparently
yeah
oh loose gun seven deuce gun 79 10 bucks
thank you on rumble uh this show is so
much more fun when you guys can speak
freely coal toll refunded fridays are
gonna be
hell yeah they are
uh
kitty
then the angry now but we only use this
one on rare
spinning a yarn
i
don't want to be here anymore i don't
want to be around anymore
i'm so glad that we're uncensored rumble
so we can make all our edgy jokes that's
right guys rumble uncensored
[Laughter]
i like benzos i like crystals meow makes
meow mix please
overall we're very happy she likes
crystals and probably likes crystal oh
she looks like someone would be like oh
i'm sorry you believe in a spaghetti god
anyway i'm in a bad mood because
mercury's in a different place
it's always these people that are like
awesome messing up my aura god the
energy isn't real
and the energy's from behind saturn
idiot
god damn it i wish it was a flat earth
there were no other planets just so we
have to hear astrology people i swear to
god that would be the only upside
also i wish
also i wish the earth was flat so that
people like you would feel compelled to
jump off the side of it no she wouldn't
she would just push stuff off the
we'd edge no icebergs left
we'd have no icebergs cat just pushing
them all off the planet stop doing that
have to spray them with a water bottle
but you're in the arctic pulse which is
the [ __ ] water freezes right away in
the air coast guard with a huge spray
bottle just [ __ ] spraying
then the happy or content meow
yeah
somebody says come on guys you're
hurting my felines
[Music]
chuck norris has gone club with a
[ __ ]
this is like imagine like dating this
trick and she's doing all this and then
at the end of her little [ __ ]
monologue you're like that's great but
you really do need to get a job like the
bills are piling up and with inflation
like everything's costing more i get you
if you want to like be a cat that's fine
but you're gonna have to be a not cat
for like a couple hours a day and do
something like either you're gonna get
have to get a job or you're going to
start having to literally eat [ __ ]
cat because guess what
and [ __ ] in a box guess what if
you're going to be a cat cats don't have
iphones
so hand it over also if you're going to
act like a cat we're gonna make you an
inside outside cat and whenever you're a
cat you're an outside cat you're an
outside cat whenever you hear that you
are an outside cat it's always an
outside cat
here's your bell see the birds don't get
you
one of the most important ones for our
kitten family is that i want to go potty
meow
what
it took me a really long time to master
this meow because
it
to master the potty meow yeah man this
is this is not beginner this is not
beginner meow [ __ ] bro this is like
[ __ ] next level virgie's laughing but
he doesn't understand that there's tears
of meowing and he'll never get that
why don't why don't you just go hey guys
i gotta take a [ __ ]
no no that's not what a cat would say
you know i want to laugh at this [ __ ]
but there's just way too many of these
people i know oh i know that's why you
that's why she could never be anywhere
near a park because she she
automatically shits in the sandbox
[Laughter]
god damn it
you like me i am so sorry about it but
at least she buries it she never does
this normally she's an inside outside
girlfriend
yeah normally she's just kind of i
really apologize they specific
in order for my kids to understand
yes
i've never heard a [ __ ] cat what's
that so
well she's mastered it bro so i would
trust her
she looks she's just she's gonna just
peek up on the counter like a cat just
see what's going on with the way her
head is
yeah when you just see the little ears
and like like half eyes
honey stop [ __ ] walking on my
keyboard you weigh 130 pounds it's
broken
it's not cute this isn't cute
anymore okay this is the most important
meow for me and it's the i need help
wiping me out
um
i'm out
i thought cats don't need help wiping i
thought they're cats i think that you're
gonna have to find a new owner
we're gonna have to find you a new
forever home
because you're right virgie i think my
cat's broken
that's good is that you know what i'm
sorry man i hate to tell you but
you have to put it down [ __ ] yo if
you're a cat does that mean i could just
legally [ __ ] curb stomp you and kill
you and then just tell everybody on
facebook you crossed the rainbow bridge
yes and there'll be no investigation
because you're a cat right
yeah talking about a drastic we don't
try to bring her up here
[Laughter]
but instead of instead of fiv she gets
hpv
[Laughter]
don't worry most of them live really
long fruitful lives even with
[Music]
okay and last but definitely not least
is our in heat meow
so this is the sexy meow get ready for
the sexy meal oh god oh god i'm sure
it's gonna be attractive
the sex the you know what the sexy male
is the sex me now is yeah [ __ ] me you
big black
what the [ __ ] lady man that did not
sound like a meow that was not a meow
that sounded like a hate crime
uh it's called race play on pornhub you
can look it up
and we use this when we need a little
bit more special kitten attention you
don't know what anything i think you
already didn't attention that would
imply adolescence wait a minute you're
mean to tell me that pedophile cat
[ __ ] you can't better cat do you mean to
tell me
well that well actually most cats like
only live to about 18 anyway so when you
think about it all cats or pedos
um
they're also all groomers
[Laughter]
but ma'am are you trying to tell me you
needed to make a meow because you
weren't getting enough attention yeah
and that you so you're saying
i feel
yeah you're telling me wow
i feel like every one of these meows was
made because she needed more attention i
hope she's fixed
again she definitely takes it in the
butt absolutely do you know when you
look at a woman you go she does anal
this woman not those only does anal she
prefers anal she's the one that brings
it up she's the one that goes she's the
one that brings it up i could only come
when you [ __ ] me in the butt which is
gonna be a clip god damn it
got him you got him
frozen's ears are ringing at his desk at
work right now they're ringing spiders
ringing
we're special
we got him
frozen's at work right now he just
turned around away
did you hear something everybody's like
no you sure
okay
he's watching the show and like his
airpods and he just slammed his [ __ ]
hand on it
everybody in the
office we hear the can we hear the final
meow please of course we can hear the
fianno meow fiano final meow piano
attention if you know what i mean
you want to get [ __ ]
[Applause]
okay so a real cat that's in heat
wouldn't sound like that dog
[Laughter]
that's the least sexy noise i've ever
heard a woman make
[ __ ] no
i thought it was fine
i thought it was fine
can we okay we gotta hear that one again
right we have to hear that one we have
the other one
forever and all okay okay here we go
here we go i think i have a new ringtone
meow and we use this when we need a
little bit more special kitten attention
if you know what i mean i get it
[Applause]
um yeah
ma'am it's gonna be my donation
ma'am this is the wendy's dumpster you
gotta leave
you gotta leave man
ma'am you have to go police pam you have
to leave right now okay